so three of the final season in case you
haven't seen part 1 of this episode I
highly suggest you to do so and then
come back and watch this video back to
the outline it says that archers
continue to rain down arrows on the
advancing army of the Dead and our
soldiers the armour the dead tries to
bridge the gates and the walls of
interval but the tall success the and
the Giants approach the gates of
interval Center calcaneus is a huge
ballast and manages to kill one giant
the hound kills a giant using huge
ballista it says but varies this huge
ballista coming from one would wonder
it's most likely coming from Castle
black back in season 4 during the battle
for Castle black we've actually seen a
giant being killed by the huge ballista
bolt shot from atop the wall with the
mention of the Nights Watch
participating in his battle it's
definitely not out of the realm of
possible raise that they brought this
huge ballista with them from the wall to
Winterfell to help winter falls defenses
however it seems like the Hound of the
huge ballista will not be enough to stop
the army of the Dead from breaching the
gates of interval it says that the
remaining two giants managed to bridge
the gates of interval Jon Snow gives an
impassioned speech encouraging everyone
to fight until their last breath his
speech rallies everyone and generally
the charge against the Horde whites will
breach the gates causing an intense
battle in the courtyard of Winterfell
John is closely followed by his direwolf
ghost arya girag injury Brienne and
Podrick the unsullied the Knights of the
Vale and the northerners accompanied in
the Tony Feud the track he fightin a
king's army
bran stark works into the undead giants
everyone fights except for Sansa branch
Samuel Sam and Gilly who are in the
crypts of interval Johnston fights the
white walkers so do Aria and Brianna or
is the first one to kill a white Walker
with a Valyrian steel dagger - a white
walkers neck Jon Snow also manages to
kill a white Walker after long duel
Brienne struggles Turman dies by saving
brain project dies by saving Tyrion
berrak the Lord said Lord serving and
Lord Royce die as well The Hound picks a
barracks flaming sword and starts
killing White's
both sides suffer huge casualties but
there's more army of the Dead at
Winterfell then there is the living it's
night and battle still rages
Winterfell is on fire caused by all the
fire arrows the living used to kill the
whites at is point most of the
northerners and the Knights of the Vale
are dead the unsullied are what keeps
the battle going I got to stop right
there to say that the battle being
fought in the night Winterfell being on
fire and the unsullied being the lone
survivors they're defending Winterfell
has been confirmed by a bunch of leaked
photos in this particularly photo we can
see the unsullied the jungle estates
fierce fighting a hoarder
White's in Winterfell it's also very
important to highlight that bran has
seemingly walked into an undead giant
which is a huge hint for the episodes to
come we've never seen bran working to
anyone from the knight king's army thus
far but now that he has it leaves a huge
possibility of brain working into the
night kings and a dragon as well at some
point of the season after all the
three-eyed raven little brain dead he
will not walk again but he will fly back
to the outline it continues with ghost
saves John multiple times sorry saves
ginjury with your bird's eye shut of a
devastating battle inside Winterfell
battle seems to be lost
John orders Arya to go to the crypts to
get her sister brother and others and
flee before it's too late
Arya refuses to leave John and sends a
few guards instead during sight at
Winterfell has used all the forces they
had in his battle and what's left of
them stands no chance to emerge
victorious at this moment two hooded men
enter the gates of Winterfell out
flanking the army of the Dead this door
dead men turn out to be Jaime bran
they're followed by the way mr. Frey
Talia army led by Admiral E I got a stop
right there to point out that this twist
might not be coming as a huge surprise
as it seems to be at first
Jaime being the savior of Winterfell has
been hinted by him and brown arriving at
Riverrun in the end of episode 2
why didn't Jaime continue traveling the
Kings Road that runs straight towards
Winterfell while he was at the
crossroads in but instead went on the
river road that runs west into the
Riverlands the answer is because he went
to River and led Lenser forces that were
sent to the Riverlands to ensure peace
and while he was at it he probably told
them more about the danger that his
nieces and nephews are facing a mere
tally then probably rarely the
Riverlands the Riverlands include the
phrase soldiers as well who now that
their Lords have been killed here most
likely switched their allegiance to Edna
anyway it's back to the outline it says
that some time later are you sorry wolf
Namira also joins the battle with her
pack wolves John Jaime and Brienne
decide to pick a fight with the
remaining white walkers while the others
fight White's
they know if they are to kill a white
Walker huge amount of whites dies along
that's their only chance with Game of
Thrones coming to its end it only makes
sense for their roles to finally
reappear ghost sees a lot of action in
this episode and amelia is now here to
John Jaime and Brienne decision to pick
a fight with the White Walkers is one of
the best choices they could have made as
seen in previous season if a white
Walker dies the whites they raised
instantly collapse as well outline
continues with jungles to White Walkers
Brienne kills one with or assault
Jaime's bested by a white Walker who
disarms him brilliance is it from a
distance
she starts running towards Jamie to save
him but her too many whites on her ray
Jamie's wounded and on his knees a white
Walker raises his sword and prepares to
swing a final blow the scene intensifies
Tyrion watches Aria steps a white Walker
from behind with a Valyrian steel dagger
the barrel turns in their favour in the
living eventually emerge victorious in
the mirror and most of our pack perish
during the battle the living has won the
battle from inter fell but most of their
armies are gone huge portion of interval
has been burned down at its moment urine
appears to the Ironborn the Lannisters
in the golden company he's been waiting
for the battle between the living and
the dead to end his their own search his
orders to kill what's left of the
winning army we see a shot of the
Ironborn in the lynnster led by urine
and the gun company led by Hera
Strickland they're marching towards
Winterfell with the war elephants John
orders everyone to form a shield wall
near the phone gates of Winterfell plans
to meet them on the gates they start
forming a formation are you sure about
that boy Jamie as Ginji looking on in
swore hammer that thing is too heavy he
continues bran agrees and says eh not
quite useful for a battle it's
exhausting trust me Genji looks on his
Warhammer and smiles John overhears
their conversation and says his King
Robert's son I think he can handle it
Jamie stunned he realized this is the
black-haired son of late Robert
Baratheon that standing beside him is
the firstborn son of King Robert and his
sister kindred and says I'm Robert's
bastard son Oh me Jane replies if you're
not
this says game she confused he says
that's what the red woman told me that's
why the golden cloaks were looking for
me Jamie replies with you're not a
bastard or the firstborn son of my
sister serves sinking Robert this
information surprises says shocks
everyone
Ginja replies and shockwave that can't
be I remember my mother she had golden
hair Jamie tribes ginjury and says
exactly the battle against your nature
and the Gullah company starts well your
ins fighting at Winterfell Theon takes
advantage of a situation in rescue
Sierra from the silence let me stop
right there to say that you're an
attacking Winterfell once the battle
between the living and the dead and to
kill what's left of the victorious
parties coming as a surprise but at the
same time it's also been kind of
confirmed by the league force in this
league photo that was taken on interval
set we can see the dead Ironborn that
would be your scheduled T's in this
battle at Winterfell does seem to be
confirming yet another major event in
the South line Jamie realizing injuries
sano King Robert and his sister search
near willing to him the truth and
everyone nearby the sling with the first
scene of this episode let me remind you
that this episode started with bran
having multiple visions of past and
future events and one has been a vision
of Cersei giving birth to a black haired
son this Sun seems to begin to himself
this turn of events will surely come as
a huge surprise to some fans but also as
the long-standing theory finally coming
true to the others anyways back to the
outline since which is back to
Winterfell
John strategy to fight search his forces
at the gates of interval works at the
start of a battle many Ironborn die the
golden company in the Lannister army
then start using the war elephants and
ladders breaching and winning the walls
that was centurion retreat with the
archers center could gain a target
wounded John realizes that they're going
to be overrun
he orders his men to lay down their
weapons and stop fighting John said
stand down everyone stand down everyone
looks at John some stop fighting some
don't Arya asks him what are you doing
most of us have already died this day
too many to afford losing more in a
fight amongst ourselves if we plan to
win this war John approaches urine and
Harry unarmed it says there's no need to
fight thousands of people don't need to
die
your smile Scotsman fan asks are you
proposing a one-on-one combat bastard
John pauses and says no take me as your
hostage and take me to your queen after
all that's what are you fighting for
right to help me defeat it on my knees
before Queen Cersei everyone is in shock
especially Jaime your reply is not on
you your dragon [ __ ] and your sister
[ __ ] to where Queen certainly censors
would like to see their heads on a spike
- since our here's it from the crypts of
Winterfell
I'm afraid they're not here so john
kerry asks verdun the nurse is with her
dragons either fighting or trying to
find a knight king and his dragon john
answers and Sansa asks sorry sensei is
at the Eyrie it's safer there
John answers here strickland and urine
agreed to take john their hostage as
they're aware they wouldn't win a fight
without for your casualties in case you
haven't seen my previous videos in which
I brought you the outlines for episode 1
- in the first part of episode 3 here's
reclaim the one who attacks Winterfell
with urine and speaks with John after
his surrounded is the leader of the
golden company few months after I
receive this outline Game of Thrones
Cathedral hare Strickland for season 8
what's happening in Sparta the outline
is that urine with sources forces in the
gun company attacks Winterfell after
they've been weakened by the night
king's army what's left of John and
Dana's armies with the support of Jaime
and Ned Mears armies still give a fight
but John decides to ended by
surrendering and offering him as a
hostage in exchange for a barrel to be
stopped John realizes that if the fight
continues they're all going to be killed
so he sacrifices himself in order to
save everyone else has this part of the
leaked outline also been confirmed one
may ask yes this major event has been
confirmed as well by numerous leaked
photos from episode four as you can see
John's novel in Episode four be escorted
through the walls of King's Landing all
the way to Queen Cersei Lannister where
they will meet and share a couple of
words the outline continues with the
next scene show us the net king in the
far south flying Nazarian is formed a
new larger army just as everyone
Winterfell suspected he would once Brent
told them about his vision the night
King raised the new army of the Dead
across Westeros by reanimating every
soldier that has died throughout the
recent wars the night King has also
tagged Dorne and now has the entire
Dorne with him - I got a step right
there to point out that at the end of
season seven we all expected NAT King to
hit Winterfell first then we so leaked
photos saw Winterfell burning and most
of us first earned a tonight King and
his dragon were behind it however as it
turns out only the knight king's army
attacked Winterfell while he's been
forming new stronger and larger army in
the far south Winterfell is being burned
down by the living side themselves
caused by the fire arrows used to kill
White's anyways back to the outline
we're back at Winterfell again
everyone's discussing what to do next
some say that they need to rescue Jon
others say that John would not want a
battle to be fought because of him most
of them agreed that they don't have
enough men for a battle instead they
decided to wait for the nearest hundred
dragons to come back and then make a
final decision one thing is certain
they're marching south Iran King's
Landing around the night King Aaron's
start speaking among themselves since
sorry and bran Brienne Jay McGinty and
hound Lyanna Mormont and Jorah Tyrion
ask Sam if he's found anything useful
from all the books his red cent else
Tyrion about an entry from the world of
Ice and Fire book that Gilly showed he
says it's about a promise hero that will
be reborn to save the world from
darkness he says it's a prophecy known
as the prince that was promised he
replies VDACS the promise hero to save
us from the long night I've heard of him
before
I wonder where was this hero today the
conversation catches more people
listening it same poses tear in the nest
seemed to tell him more about it
legendary hero Sam continues with his
name was er hi he fought the darkness
with a red sword it says that he will be
reborn as the prince that was promised
the reborn part his that was interested
that was tells them about Jon's
than how he was born Brandon reveals
every one day John is illegitimate son
of lien and prince rhaegar targaryen
which sam confirms the scene ends with
Tyrion saying the princess won today and
we've just lost him to Cersei only Jaime
replies way that we need to get him back
the episode ends with Daenerys flying
dragon followed closely by regal the
nagging is flying towards them on this
area well what an ending it seems that
the show confirms that justin is the
prince that was promised brennan same on
the other hand reveal everyone who
Joshua parents are and it seems that the
following episode might see the dance of
the Dragons within near Santiago and
accompanied with regal finally finding
the night King and his undead dragon
their heavy eyes seemingly legit outline
of Episode three Arizona